the Joe Rogan experience snoops got
diamond lower teeth now why Snoop Dogg
he's private studded or like them
creative dog old grilled diamond things
but I was he's in this video he's
driving around on his Instagram in a
Lamborghini with diamond lower teeth 50
years old diamond teeth he's living it
man all for sure he doesn't give a [ __ ]
he spends most of his time getting
furious at video games online
desi yeah he just yells about mad like
don't worry for a minute right he was
commentating like with your lyric they
would drink and watch the fight so he
was drinking liked angering smoking
joints and he's was tough because what
it was was there was some commentary
that he did just independently on one
fight and it was so hilarious because
he's so animated screaming and yelling
about this fight that everybody thought
like wow I wouldn't be great if there
was an option to watch the Snoop Dogg
commentary yeah that's right and it was
proper watch but I assume it was [ __ ]
horrific north/south yeah I guess they
got bored doing or something I don't
know it stopped maybe it was [ __ ]
busy he doesn't have time to be doing it
he's like Mike Tyson too in the sense
that I just I remember when he was like
scary I hear ya oh that's right it was a
call before it was call be ok he thought
it was but it was a man from a
completely different part of the world
yep thought it was cold
holy [ __ ] he was getting some boos the
other night huh
dude that guy hears cha-ching yep when
those people are booing Charlie it's
emotion did emotion you want to get the
emotion i people whether it's good or
bad it doesn't [ __ ] matter they want
to see him fight and they want to see
him lose he's going to heal he went
he'll listen he
a good guy I'm telling you I know that
guy I've met him outside of this crazy
thing that he's doing and this crazy
thing that he's doing came about when he
was uh like on the verge of getting cut
and people didn't like his style and so
he went hard he'll when he fought Damien
mind he went hard yeah well jail did a
similar thing Chell wasn't the big mouth
guy back in the day no he was not yeah
in one day that he's gonna be that dude
it wasn't right at the anderson fight
[ __ ] great marketing this is smart
very smart and kalbi - it's like el
Bosso colby he something happened as
well he's really exciting dude that last
fight that last fight was incredible
dude
but yeah Colby is definitely it's
contrived I appreciate the effort but
you know effective see the thing about
it being contrived is it makes it
obvious that he's putting on a show yeah
but the thing is that putting on a show
is [ __ ] he's ruthless he [ __ ] with
people's heads legitimately
like they do not want to lose to him and
then when you get inside the Octagon
he's really [ __ ] good like really
yeah I didn't realize how good he was
you see the amount of strikes the volume
and then he's an unbelievable wrestling
it's a really really really tough
matchup for anybody and Colby is it is a
you know an act and it is pro wrestling
he puts on the Trump hat and people I
mean people just see that hat and they
lose their [ __ ] mind
and he trawls half the country and it's
a similar thing with the other
businesses do it I'm going like guys
don't be rubes like it's very obvious
that it's just an act and if you're a
fan of mixed martial arts you have to
appreciate the fact that some guys are
taking chances and trying to generate
interest you could every guy can't just
be put on a suit and be straight first
and yeah I respect my opponent some
point you want to go a little story yeah
yeah I mean he makes juicier but the
bottom line is we put all that [ __ ]
aside and just look at what he's doing
you look into his doing all right that
guy is extraordinary
yeah like the fact that he could do that
to Robbie Lawler completely shut down
his offense and just put a beating on to
stay on top of him never give minière
never give him any air the pace is
smothering and if striking looked really
very good I mean very very shot takes a
shot great and his cardio is off the
[ __ ] charts oh yeah
yeah it's that that whole 170 right now
that holder
is looking crazy right now it's amazing
yeah Nate Diaz being back in the mix and
Mazda the Mazda all Nate that seems like
just like if you're a fan of just like
if you're from a poor neighborhood that
is like the the superstar match I like a
group is such a shitty like environment
it's like that was like the perfect who
hood rat [ __ ] guys who are gonna talk
[ __ ] they're gonna go in there and fight
god it's so awesome that make so much
money that's gonna be so giant well it
was cool that Dana White at the
post-fight press conference he got asked
because you know he had famously said I
think once that Nate Diaz doesn't move
the needle or something like along those
I was doing negotiation yeah I'm sure it
was but he basically said he goes I
think Nate besides a Connor and Ronda
Rousey is like about as big a star as
MMA has like they did crazy good numbers
everyone the arena was going nuts for
him he was he walked out yesterday or a
Saturday night when he walked out the
[ __ ] place roared I mean as loud as
anybody as loud as any main event person
whether it's steep a or DC Nate Diaz got
the biggest roar and then he had a great
performance but even leading up to it
people were talking about Nate coming
back more than ever talking about the
heavyweight title I don't think I don't
think some people in the UFC realized
how big a star he really is
I think they thought that the Conor
fight Conor was the big star Nate
beat'em the Conor won the second fight
Conor still remains the big superstar I
think Nate is equally as big a star but
I think that Erika as Conor's maybe
there are no Worldwide's like but in
America Nate Diaz is a giant [ __ ]
star not as big as Conor but a tier
below maybe you have to say he won the
two fights I mean if you take who would
you rather be in the two fights I mean
he choked Conor out facedown in the
first one and then had like a razor
close unbelievable great fight the
second time so I mean he comes out of
that looking pretty good yeah but I
think it's a testament to how popular
Conor is because that's the [ __ ]
Conor shine and it was a dance and Nate
brought it and Nate has that story the
one-on-one fight it's turned him into
this star button if he never danced with
Conor
who would he be that big - no I don't
know you'd know that because Nate was
awesome four years before this
incredible
do the double middle fingers like
there's so many moments where you could
where you're like I get goosebumps
thinking about making this right that's
your favorite part when it's like these
are the fingers a triangle and double
fingers and flexed you was losing that
fight too yeah oh and then the Donald
Cerrone fight third round they come out
so [ __ ] good dude meets once again
it's just you don't have to be a mixed
martial arts man he's gonna be a human
and go like that they [ __ ] fighter
that is something that everyone wants to
watch well I hope he makes an actual
belt because he's going to say he's got
the baddest [ __ ] in the game
belt and who wants to defend you know
who wants to be next to challenge for
the baddest [ __ ] in the game
belt and I love that I love that that's
his marketing strategy he should really
legitimately get a belt made up yeah
baddest [ __ ] in the game I'm
sure something like old UFC belt UFC
isn't using that old belt anymore come
on you have a bet UFC baddest
[ __ ] in the game belt and just
just just change the outside a little
bit was he smoking weed for real yes in
the open workout is he gonna get in
trouble no no no it's totally legal in
California and when you test you have to
literally be high while you're fighting
for you to test positive you saw it
dropped it all way way down
[Applause]